so it turns out the creator of
Assassin's Creed doesn't get to dive
into hay bales these days I'm Dave and
welcome to your gamespot news update
Patrice desole the creator of Assassin's
Creed who has a tumultuous past with
Ubisoft has it played a game from the
publisher since 2012 he revealed this in
an interview with edge magazine where he
admitted to being too personal I'm not a
good person to ask about how i feel
about Ubisoft games I haven't played a
Ubisoft games into 2012 I played the
first two hours of Assassin's Creed 3
and that was it with all due respect I
love you Soph very much but I cannot see
their logo on my TV screen it feels too
personal this is my floor I'm two person
with the history between the developer
and the publisher it's not surprising to
hear that he has problems with seeing
the company's logo desolee left 4 THQ
Montreal halfway through Assassin's
Creed Brotherhood's development he was
later brought back to Ubisoft in 2013
when THQ and bankrupt and Ubisoft
acquired both THQ Montreal and the
rights to desolation new game 1666
Amsterdam developer then left soon after
and then sued Ubisoft for four hundred
thousand dollars and the rights to
purchase 1666 the suit was settled this
year with the rights of the game going
to Dallas a he then started his own
studio after leaving Ubisoft and his
first game titled ancestors the
humankind Odyssey is a third-person
survival game based on certain points in
human history so what do you think about
the Creator no longer playing their game
let me know in the comment section below
or find me on Twitter at a regular Dave
and for your saturn screen news stay
tuned to gamespot com
you